in a story filled to the brim with sales
comes piccolo a namekian warrior of
extraordinary strength resolved and
because he's Akira Toriyama's favorite
character he's the one with the greatest
and quite frankly almost inexplicable
power boost in the entire series however
it is my job to try my best to explain
them and in the process find out how
strong piccolo actually is I'm totally
not mark and this is the power level
series episode for piccolo hey hey hey
hold the green man I thought my episode
was today like what gives yeah what the
[ __ ] dude uh well you see after
crunching the numbers there really
wasn't a point of reference for you guys
but don't worry I found a way to find
your respective power levels or as best
I could estimate but in order to get to
those figures I need to find Piccolo's
power level first and as soon as I do
that I'll get back to you guys straight
away and I'll do it in this video -
whatever yeah what she said
piccolo is Anna mekin warrior age 28
years old when you take into account the
roughly 40 days you spend dead and the
one year he spent in the time chamber
his techniques include the great Nanak
the special beam cannon otherwise known
as the makankosappo light grenade and
regeneration fun fact
piccolo was eight years old when he took
five-year-old go on after the radix
fight going to give you a second to wrap
your head around that one there are
seven officially stated power levels for
piccolo those being 322 408 one thousand
three hundred and thirty one thousand
four hundred eighty three hundred
twenty-nine three thousand five hundred
and over 1 million already using this
official reference as our basis let's
see if we can squeeze some more blood
from the stone it's time for some good
old-fashioned mental gymnastics at the
beginning of Dragon Ball Z Raddatz
Reeves Piccolo's full power as 408 but
by the time he touches down one year
later against NASA and Vegeta his power
has skyrocketed to 3,500 that's an
increase of 8.5 x which is enormous when
you take into account that he trained on
his own primarily while also mentoring
Gohan none of the past fighters in this
powerlevel series had been able to hold
a candle to this kind of solo
improvement so this is an important
factor icing to consider when looking at
his training in the future before we
move ahead from the Saiyan saga I'd like
to draw your attention to one other
tidbit during the raddest encounter
while wearing weighted clothing
Piccolo's power level was 322 however
Bullas remodeled Scouter reads Piccolo's
power 329 after the rats fight that is
an increase of two percent after a near
death battle from this new piece of
information I think it's fair to assume
also during the Matta fight with Crillon
and Gohan Piccolo's base power increased
the fight was longer and he played a
more major role let's say an increase of
3.5% we'll call these micro boosts for
the sake of simplicity in the future I
think it's important for me to point out
at this time that this is distinctly
different from a Saiyan
than Kaiba this booth seems to be the
result of intense exertion
so with that 3.5% boss that increases
Piccolo's power level from 3,500 to 3622
when he dies on the battlefield in
defense of go
having died piccolo along with the other
fallen fighters from the Seine invasion
quickly make it to King Kai's planet
there piccolo announces that he has
every intention to surpass Goku and that
he will help him defeat Frieza
confidently and highly-motivated he
states it alrighty so this next bit can
be a bit confusing a nuance so listen
carefully it's one of the most important
time periods for piccolo in the entire
series he gets a huge power increase on
top of that he receives some important
exposition regarding his future
piccolo on King Kai's planet confidently
states that once his training is
complete both himself and Goku would
have no trouble taking out Frieza he
however states this never having sensed
freezes energy now when piccolo is
wished back to life and transported to
Planet Namek he encounters male this is
the important part nail has an official
max power level reading of 40 mm during
this time period this is extremely
important because when piccolo finds
nail dying on the wastelands of Namek
nail expresses his astonishment at
Piccolo's power who at this point is
still wearing his weighted clothing when
goku trained on King Kai's planet he was
capable of a nineteen point five times
increase within 158 days during which he
learned the kaio-ken and the spirit bomb
piccolo was dead for fifty one day there
is no exact timeframe for how long it
took the Z Warriors to clear snake way
other than that it was done much faster
than Goku did so let's say for the sake
of keeping the ball rolling it took them
roughly two weeks
that leaves piccolo with 37 days in
which to create this vast increase large
enough to warrant nails astonishment
some interesting tidbits from the
interaction between the two namekians
are the comments male makes regarding
the benefits of merging with comic
saying that if he had done so he might
be able to defeat Frieza nail however
states this having no knowledge of
freezes to abilities or transformation
any way for nails to be astonished
Piccolo's power would need to be way
over 40 mm but not strong enough to
defeat Frieza
nail can sense key and therefore knows
or should have an idea of the other huge
powers on the planet nail was the
appointed protector of guru and
therefore would have been on the lookout
for these kind of things so he would of
course had been aware of Goku sudden
rise to 180,000 during his demonstration
of the kaio-ken versus captain ginyu so
using that information I can estimate
that he believed freeze it to be between
200,000 and its fur
for max of 530,000 he is certain that
piccolo would die if he chose to fight
Frieza without taking him up on his
offer to fuse with it so he is much
stronger than nail and is much weaker
than what Frieza demonstrated to nail so
again for the sake of progress let's
guess that he is somewhere in the region
of 80,000 to 110,000 meaning he
multiplied his power between 22 and 30
times over so let's assume that piccolo
is a 110,000 by the time he lands the
battlefield would nail because Torrio
whether or not you agree with my method
to get to this figure this is the only
figure that satisfies the conditions of
the narrative as a whole the merging
would nail resulted in piccolo gaining a
power level over 1 million we all know
this as he managed to get the better of
second form Frieza which is confirmed to
have a power level of over 1 million
also so for simplicity's sake it's fair
to assume given how the fight went
if Frieza was around 1.1 million piccolo
would be around 1.2 million at this
point if this is true this means his
fusion with nail yielded at 11 times
multiplier I suppose it's to be expected
from nameks number one son now keeping
these micro boosts in mind also seeing
as the bow but Frieza was greater it
would be worth more but I am also
keeping in mind that he didn't
participate as much he had in prior
fight so I'll give him a boost of 4%
bringing him to 1 million 248,000 these
micro boosts didn't apply to the entries
prior in the power level series as I had
no evidence to prove they attained any
boost and had no means to gain or an
estimate percentage based on their
respective effort ok so this next bit
might be controversial but ignoring the
obvious character bias that Toriyama has
for piccolo this is the only theory I
could map out that accounts for the
frankly preposterous power of piccolo
gets between the events of Namek and the
Android saga so let's break this down
regarding the Meccan fusion male worked
well and yielded a high multiplier
because nail was a fighting prodigy like
piccolo they were similar bills and
sizes and they were both warrior type
the meccans but I don't believe this is
where nails contribution to piccolo
ended certainly not if my mental
gymnastics had anything to say about it
my theory is that nail had his power
previously unlocked by guru which would
make sense he was after all the
protector of the grand elder thus by
proxy could have unleashed Piccolo's
potential when they merged similar to
Crillon going from the mid 1075
in a short span of time which is in and
of itself a 42 times increase piccolo
could have had his power creep up slowly
through training after these events
after all we all know that spicing
ability strength and knowledge can be
passed through merging so why not this
because if not this we all need to
accept a piccolo magically garnered a
metric rap to the power in the span of
four years through regular training now
let me be clear
piccolo is objectively astronomically
stronger fighting the androids that he
was uh Namek and so given the
information that I have found this
thing's being for me the only plausible
explanation for such an enormous power
boost following this train of thought
however we don't know is there anything
that causes this power up to accelerate
or if it requires anything and simply
moves up on its own
piccolo saw much less action than
Crillon who was also brought back to
full health after battle therefore
spending much more time healthy currents
42 times increase isn't a concrete
converter either Gohan had more and then
they had less so again for the sake of
keeping the ball rolling let's give him
a 17 times multiplier which is kind of
in the middle of what I was talking
about during a little on the low side
this at least gives us some context for
how he manages to stay relevant in this
series and competitive amongst the Super
Saiyans besides the fact that he's
Toriyama's favorite taking these figures
into account we can work out the
Piccolo's power by the time he begins
training for the androids is twenty-one
million two hundred and sixteen thousand
moving swiftly along this back and forth
could be indicative of piccolo being
more powerful than Vegeta at this point
even though Vegeta clearly passed well
over 1.2 million while fighting Frieza
unyk after this piccolo trains for
additional three years in preparation
for the androids invasion I came up with
this boss based on the results of past
training sessions over the course of a
year or more in prep for the same
invasion he trained for one year and
gave himself at 8.5 x boost in power but
between the piccolo jr arc and the right
attack over five years past and he only
garnered somewhere in the region of 33
to 40 percent of a buff so I decided to
give him a regular 8.5 x power boost
over the course of those three years
bringing his total power level on the
day of the androids were activated to
180 million three hundred and thirty six
thousand after all I am working under
the pretense that his Power had been
unlocked so naturally there will be a
slow in the amount of power would rise
through
t'rul training me during this time
period piccolo scuffles with Android 20
at this stage piccolo while not being as
strong as Vegeta is regularly in the
same conversation as if trunks was
roughly 150 million to 180 million
whilst fighting freezer since Frieza was
more powerful upon return so in order
for piccolo to be in the Super Saiyan
conversation it makes sense for his
power to be as I stated around 180
million with this power he is capable of
easily disposing of dr. Gero who
foolishly used logic to anticipate their
growth rate the next major moment of
significance particular comes when here
emerges with coming at different point
in the series both piccolo and coming
are referred to as to have with the
information we gather from the manga we
learned the piccolo becomes the host
body for the merging as he is younger
and stronger than coming with this
knowledge we can discern that he doubles
and strength if they are in fact two
halves
adding both the knowledge and experience
of Comet to the host body
piccolo this brings Piccolo's overall
power level to that of 360 million six
hundred and seventy two thousand which
reminds me I think now is a good time to
check back in with our Android friends
piccolo take five gotcha Android 17 and
Android 18 aka lapis and lazuli are
human type Earthlings with biomechanical
enhancements with an approximate
physical age of about 17 years old both
can fly without the use of ki and have
techniques which include now we're
playing for keeps tower blitz and the
Android barrier in the Dragonball cannon
and in the encyclopedic Dyson Xiu books
we are told time and again that 17 and
18 were humans taken against their will
and forcefully transformed by dr. Gero
within this panel you can see that form
of use dr. DeRose blueprints of the
twins which informs of their largely non
mechanical nature the only mechanical
parts being emergency stop and
self-destruct to be exact a cyborg is a
human being that integrates
or enhances itself with external
feedback systems be they mechanical
chemical or otherwise there is a lot of
details to discuss left in this topic
but I'll leave it there they are cyborgs
non androids androids is a
mistranslation if you would like to read
more in depth about this topic I will
leave a link in the description down
below that said I'm a lazy creature of
habit and will not actively try to call
them slave
from now on but just so we're clear the
androids are cyborgs now on tomorrow
Android stuff regarding their power two
things are important to consider when
talking about the androids they have
infinite energy and their key cannot be
sensed these two points I think are
important to remember when looking at
the androids battle potential the whole
reason why so many fights in Dragonball
come to an end is due to fatigue either
the hero or the antagonist succumb to
exhaustion and as a result get their
comeuppance this quote further hones in
on my estimate for the Android power
level stronger than Super Saiyan Vegeta
around this time period using all the
information we know about the androids
we can infer that at this point Android
17 is as strong as merged come a piccolo
at 360 million I'm estimating he is
slightly lower based on the fact that
Android 17 struggled for a small portion
of the fight before piccolo began to
fatigue it's important to note that the
term fatigue means to tire and as a
result power levels will sharply decline
the same is true for anyone on the
planet in the real world it doesn't
matter how much you can lift if you're
tired here is weak as any of us that's
one of the biggest things working in the
androids favor they do not tire when
trying to infer both of the androids
power levels I think it's important to
look at this quote this statement is
indicative of both Android 17 and 18
having similar power levels close if not
identical but that's not enough this is
the power level series I'm not just
going to give up
so let's take a closer look during my
initial research trying to find out
which of the two twins was in fact the
strongest I stumbled upon this image it
looks as though it answered my question
perfectly but I couldn't find the source
of the image or the suppose at interview
it was quoting the image I later learned
was a doctored fake from one of the
final pages of volume 15 of the manga
the original image regarding enjoyed 17
states too much attention was placed on
the power capabilities so it refused to
take orders failure and regarding 18 it
states although its power was suppressed
compared to 17 it also did not follow
orders failure this is undisputable
confirmation that Android 17 is the
stronger of the two androids it's
difficult to discern by what margin 17
is stronger than 18 after looking at
past quotes it cannot be by much but not
enough information is available
to draw any accurate comparison so again
for the sake of forward momentum in this
video 17 must be around piccolo star
level of 360 million he says that during
his fight piccolo was on power with him
but as piccolo stamina wavered the gas
began to widen due to Android 17 the
limitless energy so keeping in mind that
this is a conservative estimate based on
Android 18th battle with Vegeta I would
put Android 18 somewhere in the region
of 330 million it could however be
closer or further from Android 17s level
this is just an estimate based on what I
have to work with it's important to note
also that their power levels have not
diminish at all since the cell saga they
do not Stratego an endless energy
therefore their bodies do not break down
regardless of whether or not training
has been done or if they have sat on
their ass for 10 years their power level
cannot diminish now back to the green
guy so at this point piccolo is the
strongest Z warrior by far surpassing
even the Super Saiyan fun fact this is
the second time in this series where
piccolo is the strongest fighter the
first being back we was finding second
form Frieza UNMIK after newly merging
with nail once Piccolo's fight with
Android 17 comes to a close I will not
award him any micro boost at this point
piccolo power is fully unlocked and
fully realized and any increase after
this it slowed greatly once cell absorbs
the two androids piccolo proceeds to the
time chamber where he trains for one
year on his own once piccolo exits the
chamber Goku and piccolo have this back
and forth it's worth knowing that goku
makes this statement after attaining
super saiyan grade 4 or full powered
super saiyan being in this state he is
still much stronger than piccolo and
still no match for full power perfect
cell so what kind of increase does
piccolo gain while in the chamber in
calculating this I'm trying to stay in
line with the story of the show and
trying to be fair knowing what we know
about Piccolo's character piccolo axis
mode is fully realized he is fully
merged or complete and using my excuse
for his enormous boost in power has had
his power unlocked also currently he's
running on the most optimum setting so
to speak in the past there have been two
instances that demonstrate the result of
piccolo straining walls so low that
being the span of time from his defeat
the hands of Goku to the arrival of
riders which over five years he roasts
level from somewhere in the 300 to 400
so at most he gained a 36% buff overall
during his training with Gohan however
we know that he gained substantially
more given to the span of time he had to
work in the chamber was for one year
taking everything into account that he
has already fully realized and merged
and his time frame for improvement is
short and that he was training on his
own I will award him a 50% buff which
might not seem like much but remember he
only managed a 36% increase over 5 years
before so really this might even be too
high but let's highball this
so with that increase it results in a
power level that I've estimated to be
around 541 million eight thousand when
he leaves the time chamber in
preparation for perfect cell the only
other significant family participates in
in the cell saga comes against the cell
juniors again I will not award any micro
boosts for reasons previously stated at
this point
piccolo doesn't have a goal and the
world is in an era of peace that's not
to say that he doesn't keep training in
past times of peace piccolo trained
intensely however a gap has been created
that he might view as insurmountable
motivation has always been what drives
our characters to become stronger so
that for me is one of the biggest things
to consider when gauging how strong
characters would become over extended
periods of time taking all of this into
account I will give piccolo a 25% buff
over the boot I'm skip of 7 years
note that the growth of his power is
slowing down dramatically
this is observed in the story also note
that at this point he is much weaker
than Gohan while Gohan himself has
gotten weaker since the cell saga
bringing him to an estimated power level
of 683 million
22600 at the end of the boo saga during
the time skip I would imagine piccolo
has become more comfortable and trained
less not because he has lost interest in
training but mostly due to the fact that
he cares for Gohan and his family our
first time seeing piccolo in Super comes
in the very first episode when he stands
atop a building keeping an eye on Gohan
and Videl as they go about their
business during the day during the
events of the resurrection of s Park he
participates in a lengthy fight with the
freedom force as well as fighting the
freezer elite like she saw me and
togarmah
after that he is a very brief showing in
the universe sixth tournament followed
by no observed activity since with the
likelihood of him taking care of ten
more and more weighing up all the pros
and cons I believe piccolo to be
somewhere in the region of 717 million
one hundred and seventy three thousand
seven
30 by the time he joins universe 7 squad
so let's recap no info has been made
available for the training of 18 or 17
so I will leave them as they were during
the cell saga
however if new information arises
obviously then their levels change
so from weakest and strongest we see
Android 18 with a power level of roughly
330 million we see Android 17 with the
power of roughly 360 million and piccolo
with a final power level of what I would
believe to be in the region of seven
hundred and seventeen million one
hundred and seventy three thousand seven
hundred and thirty anyone that knows
Piccolo's character and really acted
this video you probably know him better
than any character in the show does he
is an amazing strategist with a unique
moveset being Toriyama's favorite
character who knows something amazing
might happen with him he has on arguably
one of the best character arcs in the
entire series and I honestly can't wait
to see what dynamic both him and the
androids will bring to the squad I
really hope you guys enjoyed the video
don't forget to leave a like if you did
enjoy it and if you guys would like to
see more from me in the future please
hit the subscribe button down below this
has been the power level series I've
been totally not mark thank you so much
for watching